what do you think of it and what do you
think of this what do you think of this
because i'm just trying to think you
know you guys are hollywood i'm trying
to think hollywood mine so what do you
think of this
we get the movie that comes out pandemic
2020 who gets two years
we fund it we got uh dr fauci we got him
played by joe pesci
uh we got martin scorsese directing it
okay we got uh
donald trump we'll have him uh played by
alec baldwin and then for the corona
virus i was thinking we have that played
by bobby lee what do you think
hold on hold on dude again i mean i
don't think i don't want bobby lee
i again i'm i'm taking offense a little
bit because bobby lee's korean
he's really american and you want him to
play
a virus i mean i want to get this chris
no because i just because the virus they
say is a little
virus and i you know he's a shorter guy
no no he'd be patient zero maybe no yeah
maybe kills on stage
nope nope bill's on stage i don't like
this i don't like this movie
what about ronnie chang nope see again
you're
no but there's you're you're you're
focusing on the wrong thing i'm not i'm
saying i'm saying funny comedians
that that kill you know to play with the
crown of ours so bobby lee or ronnie
chang or margaret cho
no there's no i'm just no
you're talking about all all of these
people are korean again and you're
lumping in koreans with chinese i
already find that offensive and i'm
gonna have to ask you to
to maybe maybe suggest a white guy to
play the virus
just sorry all inclusive i would say
quarantine's made him a little racist
but he was like this before you become a
little racist
warranty has turned you into a bit of a
racist i'm i'm just kidding around i
hope the fans don't just kidding as i
said it the first time i came out i'm
one of the biggest i have the biggest
transgender uh fan base for many
podcasts and now we have
we tried to we tried to verify that
chris and we really couldn't see any
hard to find stats on that hard to find
stats on that dude on the mountain bike
the bike seats they're pretty small man
like this they hurt my [ __ ] and they
go you can now you have uh
like you know when you change the gears
on the left side you push it and it goes
up and down
really yeah doesn't it hurt your doesn't
it hurts people are saying that like go
enjoy your
taint have no issues not a [ __ ] i have
no issues but that area isn't exactly
muscular it's hard to get muscle
in your taint but i've been riding that
peloton for like two or three years now
so i think it's used to it you got a
little callus on your on your taint
yeah like a sumo wrestler yeah you know
it's all brown around yeah yeah
yeah area is a little spongy but you
must have a couched up a little bit yeah
like a battleship
right under your balls right under your
nutters like you're like
just some mollusk
but yeah you can control the seat down
or up because when you're going down
like if you're going down the mountain
you don't want it all the way up
because then you're gonna [ __ ] hit
special bike shorts jack
uh i have some spandex i'll bust out
every now and then is that right i do
what do you do with your deck
well i just kind of tuck it in there's a
guy white guy preppy white looking guy
very nice hair probably 28 on the way
here
he's on he's right on lincoln boulevard
he is selling masks he's in a superman
costume
i'm going to take a picture i should
have taken a picture he's in a superman
costume
hairs with a mask uh blue gloves and
he's holding
face masks he's selling them and i can
see his shitty dick
he's not wearing underwear i can see the
outline perfectly of his shitty dick
and he's wondering why no one's buying
his mask i was like how the [ __ ] did
that happen
if you have to sell masks in your maybe
he doesn't yeah you're down maybe he
just doesn't know his dick's hanging out
he
i looked at him and i went this is the
whole time
this is the whole problem with you i'm
gonna get on the way back i hope he's
still there but i went oh i like
this this is cool right so there's like
a couple goals i'll play it for you
this is old though okay watch this
yeah great so he plays for the chiefs
right kansas city or something like that
that's his girl
redskins though redskins all right
so that's kayla cason and her boyfriend
tj thorpe from the redskins
yeah okay
tight right cool you and i should have a
handshake
let's do one please hold on
no you gotta do it
too gay okay let me try it again
whoa easy cowboy easy
cowboy i'm living my life over here man
don't be grabbing at the room
dmt together yeah that was the best
thing ever it might have been the best
thing ever was it
i thought so it was all right oh i
thought it was not like i have to i
would do it 100 i would do it again yeah
i thought it was mine i never think
about it until you just
we're not drug i mean it's like it's not
like it changes your whole
you know anytime anybody tells you about
a transformation i saw this guy
dude i'm telling you he takes you to a
different like i change look at the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah no no i don't want to never hear
anyone who's happy going i did this drug
and it changed
my life man i'm so much better that's
right mm-hmm that's right that's right i
agree
never eat a chocolate bar [ __ ] found
a way
i think psychedelics can have positive
effects i'm not a big psychedelic guy
but
i'd be down to try rogan is pretty
articulate about it
you know i don't know there's a bunch of
you have punched people swear by if it
works for you do it
sam harris talks about it in his book uh
spirituality without religion
you know there's certain things that can
give you a perspective yeah certain
psychedelics but
i like the reset idea yeah you know
psychedelics resetting you
where they reset your like if you have
anxiety if you have some sort of stuff
issues
like reset your brain to like i think
all of this is whatever i think at the
end of the day human beings have a
purpose find out what your purpose is
and follow it to its end
and try to be excellent at it i think
that is the first thing
and then the other stuff you can do on
the side but the first thing is
what do you what are you supposed to do
stand up you know stand up
stand up never the challenge never goes
away you're always learning about
yourself
you're always you know and whatever you
do besides that okay but
follow your to hear the rest of this
motivational talk
1999. follow your adderall and cater all
you gotta you get
an adderall and then you get you talked
about kids doing adderall all day
following you didn't give a motivational
speech at the end
i didn't tell kids to do at all you
[ __ ] stop
stop characterizing me as a pusher
doesn't feel better than any other world
yes the point is
you shouldn't do it i'm out of here man
can we give it to kids
god damn it i gotta get out of here is
there an l.a chapter or is it just you
oh the la chapter's the biggest chapter
papa it was created in l.a
it's international though all right
don't you see my instagram
no i don't watch that australia iran
iraq
south korea i didn't see any of that i
didn't see south korea in iran
uk i didn't see iraq and iran all over
yeah
thailand had some big dump thick
grilling in thailand
i think it's thailand just a big old
girl on a bike really so can i be and i
was i guess
still reviewing an application what do
you have to do
what is the criteria when you look at my
application what are you looking at
what i ask can't be in the club wait
what what are the things that might
disqualify so you're saying there's a
chance i could
i could have my i could be disqual
disqualified barred from entering yeah
dude
there's a chance i mean who's doing
we're like what you're looking at more
likely than wait
so you're the guy so what do you what is
the criteria you know me why can't i be
part of the thick boy bike club now
i'll be the thin boy representative just
not you get injured all the time you
don't commit
i don't get injured all the time i'm
pretty injury-free the big one is you
gotta own a bike
well you said you'd get me one no you
papa you gotta buy me the bike for
stealing all those yeah but other people
have been
i'm sure there people reach out and
we'll hook you up with a bike i've
already had that
i have don't tell what it is
well first of all his hair has never
looked like ever in his
in his life when he was born he wasn't
born with that puerto rican
yeah you look like you should be in
glendale
my friend
yeah i don't know why we're both so dark
yeah no that is a summertime picture
right there
i mean and you're you look
auschwitzy like your space is so thin
bro
like you look like you've been on the
keto for a long time
oh my god yeah i look pretty like
because his head looks way bigger than
yours
is it no it's not right here's tough
what's the biggest woman you've ever
come across close to that dude
i don't i'm not a bee yeah i don't know
you have you ever been with a woman
who's tipping 200
no no i've been with me too i have my
dick goes i don't think so dude
i've been with a and a couple when i was
younger there was a girl who was just a
big girl that was curvy i'd always
wanted to have sex
you don't know carter yeah i've all i
had always wanted to have sex with a
woman who looked like nell carter all
right can you bring up nell carter yeah
yeah
so this it had always been on my list of
i had always wanted to have
sex yeah with it
if you want to have sex with derek
poston i'll call him up
i don't know if he's into that but they
look identified
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh dude oh my god look
at that
yeah man oh i saw there was this woman i
was bartending one night so those are
nails
that's not her i was i was bartending
one night
and um there was a woman sitting at the
end of the bar and she had been there
all night by herself
and i asked her towards the end of the
night what are you doing she was like i
stood up
and i oh and she had been making me
laugh all night this girl no no no not
nell carter but a woman who looked like
no carter
and so i said uh we were closing down
and i always went and got pancakes after
work and i go you want to have pancakes
with me she was yeah she'd be making so
we got pancakes we're laughing the whole
time
and she was in the middle dude she had
just cut off the biggest bite that any
human being
could put in their mouth she's a big
girl puts the fork of pancakes in her
mouth and looks right at me and starts
to chew and she goes
so we [ __ ] are what
and i was like yeah we absolutely are
uh-huh and it was game on it was game on
man i will tell you it was different
you know when there's so many there's
yeah there's
there's different smells that come out
of different
you know what i mean because i don't
that's nice
i plant-based protein let's go back to
the plant-based protein shake you were
having
was that at least you're eating clean
hey man i just like to sample a little
bit of everything just to see
what i don't like and whatever well i've
never had my balls set on fire
but you do drink raw milk so yeah not
anymore i don't
i used to have to i used to take when i
was single i used to take the kids to
movie theaters
for naps but and i would fall asleep
because the only time but i would make
sure i was touching all three of them
so if they would steal oh dude right
that i would know they moved
there was one time we went and saw a
long time ago what was that adam sandler
movie switch snitch with the
remote control switch uh no um
switch right with the remote control
switch
sad movie that's the thing i was in
there there was a father-son scene
and i started to tear up a little bit
super my son leans over to me and he
goes
hey you crying i go yeah and he goes get
it together
[Laughter]
so you guys you got him switches
click's a great one yeah man but that
had like uh onward have you seen onward
well your kids aren't
young onward is a it's a new disney
movie
it's so goddamn good but it's about two
brothers one older brother one younger
just like my kids when older one younger
and their dad pass away and they have
magic to bring him back oh yeah
his feet his body because they try the
magic and just his feet come back
so they're searching to find the rest
like this magic formula
to bring the whole dad back and then at
the spoiler in three two one
so the the kids go through this whole
journey and at the end the younger
brother realizes
that his older brother was showing him
and like he was the father figure
dude did you cry oh
i teared up a little bit yeah i teared
up i'm going to talking a lot
i'm not sure if you ever saw that movie
up oh yeah
first five minutes i'm crying i'm like
am i [ __ ] crying in the first
five minutes sequence the secrets are so
good it's so
good oh my god this you've never seen
this brian
i've never seen any of those movies but
i hear they're you're saying minions or
despicable me
i've
which is the one for me with my kids
lion king i probably saw
i don't know they're kids man i got four
grandkids dude
that's right so dude you have four
grandkids i can't believe you were a
single dad the last time i sparred
was in a sparring class and it was three
guys and three girls
and the dude who was running was like
hey you're gonna spar with jared was a
woman
and i go um can i start with a guy and
she goes he goes no you're gonna spy
with jared
and i said to her hey i'm not gonna hit
you and she know what she said to me
i know now i thought she meant i
she knew i was gonna be polite oh wow so
i had never been
leg kicked before here oh man dude
she got me twice there the second time
hurts so much did you drop a [ __ ] i
dropped no i dropped my left arm when
she lifted her leg up
she knocked my mouthpiece out of my it
my whole head just
look across you up bang bang does it
fakes and then boom
oh it was so embarrassing that i just
ran right at her
and i said to her i'm sorry and i ran
right
i ran right here i not
toast you available that i don't like
tortellini no no i don't like these
things you have to call me brian
why dude i i like you got a nice little
shaved head i mean you're [ __ ] you
look good baby got a nice little pump
yeah i got a pump i do all right i mean
i train i train i know days off you know
what i'm saying no david
dude yeah absolutely so what what'd you
say chicken no
i don't know you can't call me these
chickens you're objectifying me
and it's secretive this this was i saw
this on espn's
dude people keep tagging me really what
the [ __ ] is this disgusting
fake boy thick boy goals i don't know if
i'm ever get this level no
dude i'm too thick for this look at this
[ __ ] guy killian
i guess he's a professional mountain
biker but check them out riding on this
cliff
these are how creepy is that new zealand
chapter right
are you [ __ ] joking me fall off it's
game set match he's on one he's a
wheelie he's wheeling it
he's obviously a pro oh my god a pro
yeah yeah
yeah oh my [ __ ] god yeah look at this
well this is where the bike becomes
exactly like your feet there's just no
difference i mean that's so [ __ ]
crazy
wow he's going fast dude one little slip
what the [ __ ] yeah absolutely not jesus
christ
what in the actual [ __ ] is going on
that's so amazing insane huh that's
insane that's insane
that's there's no reason to do that when
you see my back ripple and i pull myself
up like a chimp
like a chimp 30 times while talking to
you
why wouldn't i give that to you as it's
a gift it's a gift
it's a gift